what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so a lot of you guys have been
asking about Rob core rings fYI if you
follow me on twitter at comics explained
um I usually just kind of give rings
away arbitrarily you know follow me on
Twitter and and that's where you'll find
out whether or not I give him away but
okay so Marvel announced that cosmic
Ghost Rider was going to get his own
solo series and I was like okay um well
this is a solo series or like a mini
series or what but he's gonna have his
own comic book and initially I was on
the fence about it and then I read this
and I'm like okay so I am on board if
Donnie Cates is the one who's writing it
I am on board with it this guy is a
madman who Donna Cates this guy's
smashing out some of the best they know
storytelling ever but cosmic Ghost Rider
is so cool he's hilarious because the
initial thought of everybody who was
reading the Thanos series was the cosmic
Ghost Rider was Deadpool that like
Deadpool had somehow become the Ghost
Rider but it's not Deadpool instead what
we end up doing here is picking up with
like this lost battle that takes place
on earth is basically the final time if
Thanos invades and this is cool I love
these montage things where it's just
like the final battle of Earth and like
everyone's basically dying I love those
kinds of stories they're so cool but
like this final battle of Earth is
intense because like everybody's getting
totally obliterated but what is it
happening is that in these final moments
when basically everybody's dying and
being obliterated the Punisher reaches
out and says I would give anything to
kill thanos and he's whisked in front of
a fist oh this is huge because those are
guys who don't know the Ghost Rider is a
byproduct of Mephisto now the purpose of
the Ghost Rider has watched and waned
over the years the Ghost Rider is in and
of itself a spirit of vengeance now like
the Ghost Rider Robbie ray is is not the
same as like Danny ketch or Johnny Blaze
those two guys Johnny Blaze and Danny
ketch their spirits of vengeance so they
have like the penance stare but they're
basically sent there like they they have
the power of the Ghost Rider given
directly to them by Mephisto when it
comes to Audie Reyes he's just possessed
by Eli I want to say I cannot I could
never ever his last name but basically
his uncle like the spirit of this you
know demonic worshipping uncle and that
was really about it
no Marvel's brought the mythos of Robby
Reyes closer in line with like you know
Johnny Blaze and Danny ketch but for the
most part he's kind of a standalone
isolated character but as you see this
circumstance now this is classic Ghost
Rider circumstance being brought before
Mephisto basically being told I can make
your wish come true but you will have to
serve as the Ghost Rider and that's
exactly what ends up happening the irony
of all this and one thing to keep in
mind is that when it comes to Mephisto
his whole
is he basically bargains with people and
then he takes their souls once they're
dead and so it's never one of these
things where like he's legit like he's
never fair I'm so sure
Punisher becomes the Ghost Rider in
order to destroy Thanos the problem is
he can't leave earth he's confined to
the planet Earth because he can't fly he
can't survive in space on his own and so
the result is that he's essentially
doomed just kind of ride around the face
of the earth forever but the funny thing
about this is that he basically loses
his mind in complete and total isolation
and this is the explanation of why it is
that Ghost Rider is more like Deadpool
now than he originally was because the
indication is that when Frank castle
became Ghost Rider he was probably a lot
like Johnny Blaze but being left in
isolation having no one to talk to the
fact of the Punishers entire Charter his
entire existence is predicated on like
tracking down those who have committed
wrongs and then just executing him on
the spot being judged during an
executioner because that's not there he
quite literally just went insane and so
I would surmise that in effect he became
Deadpool now from here we pick up with
the arrival of Galactus and under normal
circumstances when it comes to these end
of the worlds stories you know like
after all those superheroes have been
destroyed Galactus will usually show up
at least depending on who's writing the
story because it's like okay no one's
here to protect earth and it's high time
that I consumed it that's what happened
in the future of the old man Logan story
but the problem is that Galactus hasn't
shown up to earth to consume it Galactus
has shown up to earth for asylum he
should have to earth believing that all
the earth superheroes are still here and
he's seeking aid and the reason why is
because while Ghost Rider yacht while
Punisher is on earth is kind of confined
to this planet Thanos has been launching
a campaign just kind of hop skipping and
jumping across the universe obliterating
every form of sentient life he comes
across
he's killed gods he's killed cosmic
entities and Thanos is yet another
person in his line of sight now of
course Thanos basically escaped with his
life but this is designed to illustrate
the fact that Thanos his power has been
growing consistently over the years now
again this is an origin story yanked out
of the Thanos wind story arc and Medanos
when story arc explains all that it
tells us how all that happened you know
tells us everything that's going on so
again once we cover like the main story
itself then like we'll see everything
that's going on so you guys will
basically have an idea what's happening
but it is cool because with Galactus
showing up here he's basically met by
cosmic Ghost Rider and the funny thing
is a Galactus kind of doesn't know how
to handle it it's like going to a party
that you're expecting like everybody to
be yet but the only one who's there is
just like the weird guy nobody wants to
talk to you like okay so I forgot
that I have something to do and that
something is not being here so like good
we'll see you later
but it's kind of funny but the idea is
that what is up happening as is cosmic
gross right oh really at this point just
Ghost Rider comes to the realization
that he and Galactus have a common theme
and under normal circumstances when it
comes to like allies Galactus is someone
you want to have on your side because of
all the power he possesses and the
result is that you know coach rider so
he says hey look man like you want to
destroy Thanos I want to destroy Thanos
let's work together and so Ghost Rider
becomes cosmic Ghost Rider and that's
why this is cool is because now he's
simply a Herald of Galactus now the
funny thing is that this doesn't happen
like right off the bat right it's not
like cosmic Ghost Rider becomes a Herald
of Galactus and then in turn like three
hours later they're facing off against
Thanos this goes on for like centuries
it goes on for like a long long time now
the indication seems to be that like
they're tracking down Thanos right and
that's kind of the weird situation here
is because we would expect Galactus with
the power cosmic to be able to easily
locate Thanos but I would argue that
because of the fact that Marvel wants to
kind of create a like an ongoing series
for for you know cosmic Ghost Rider that
this is likely a way for them to
basically create a gap to say okay so
like now what we're gonna get in this
solo series is what amounts to the tales
of cosmic Ghost Rider what were caused
but what was consummate Ghost Rider and
Galactus doing what were they doing
together when they were like surfing
this space waste but it is cool because
once they finally face-off against him
like danos just destroys Galactus he
just blows his head off
is this like no fight at all and this is
intense because again this hits at the
idea that Thanos his power has been
growing over the years but it is cool
because Thanos basically offers an olive
branch of friendship to Ghost Rider and
the reason why is because remember and
Marvel Comics while the spirit of
vengeance can possess people the spirit
of vengeance itself is kind of an
immutable entity it is just sort of a
force that's out there that sent forward
by Mephisto so the physical body of
Frank Castle could be destroyed but the
spirit of vengeance would be whisked
back by Mephisto and then given to
someone else
and when you're Thanos when you're
looking at a person that has the powers
of the Ghost Rider the powers of the
spirit of vengeance you really see
Punisher Punisher the Punisher was just
a guy who ran around on earth and was
judge jury and executioner for everyone
he disagreed with but let's say for
example the town's destroyed the
physical body of the Punisher then again
the spirit of vengeance would be whisked
back to Mephisto and it would just stay
there until Mephisto finds somebody else
he can basically trick into becoming the
the new Ghost Rider and then bond that
to that person and it would just take
someone out there anybody or anybody in
the universe and suddenly the cycle
repeats itself in order for the Ghost
Rider entity to be as close as you can
get to destroyed Thanos would have to go
to the realm of Mephisto kill him and
then in turn like destroy whoever
whoever the Ghost Rider is inhabiting
right now and all that would happen is
the spirit of vengeance would whisk back
to the realm of Mephisto and there
wouldn't be anybody to send it forward
again until somebody took over the role
of Mephisto if anybody did and so again
that's how that whole thing works but
again if Thanos aligned himself with
cosmic Ghost Rider simply saying hey
look it's better to simply have you on
my side that have to worry about you
killing me somewhere along the line or
the spirit constantly coming back so it
is kind of cool because as a result this
is how it is that Ghost Rider becomes an
ally of Thanos now because of the fact
that Frank Castle and the Ghost Rider
kind of have a synonymous or you know an
almost identical charter in the sense
that they exist to punish the wicked the
analyst at weight starts taking him
around the cosmos and they just start
killing and destroying it and anyone
that that gets in their way basically
anyone who's deemed to be an evildoer in
the eyes of Frank Castle and the eyes of
the spirit of vengeance and so as a
result what is up happening here is you
end up having them facing off against
the Silver Surfer who is believed to
have been dead now what the Silver
Surfer is also done here is travel to
the negative zone and marshal the forces
of Annihilus now if those you guys don't
know the negative zone is kind of like a
hallway of doors when it comes to Marvel
Comics and Marvel you have like the
multiverse you have all these different
universes but there's only one negative
zone so if they were to introduce the
negative zone in like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe if they follow comic
book logic if they follow the way it's
depicted in Marvel Comics then like
Doctor Strange could enter the negative
zone and then like access any one of the
universes in the multiverse which
includes the main Marvel comic book
universe like assuming that it's all
part of the great big huge multiverse
but within the negative zone it is a
self-contained reality you've got
planets you've got stars I think you
have stars but you have like alien oh
dinners and races and you have all kinds
of things that go on but the leader of
the negative zone or the person kind of
you know the most empowered is a
nihilist and Annihilus has the
annihilation wave which is basically
just a giant army of bugs but while he's
tried to invade the Marvel Universe and
successfully did it while he tried to
conquer the universe and came close
ultimately he was defeated and confined
back to the negative zone again but the
annihilation wave numbers in the
millions if not the hundreds of millions
I mean it was a force large enough to
just kind of make its way to literally
be a wave across the universe and
destroy like Cynthia in life and
why planets and destroy all these things
to the point that like the various
groups and heroes who were out there
running the accuser star-lord
Peter quill they were like fleeing for
their lives and they were fighting a
losing battle it was so bad that like
Nova Richard Ryder showed up to earth
during the events of civil war was like
hey guys so like you guys need to come
help us fight only to find out that like
the earth superheroes were fighting
amongst each other and then he just left
it was pretty huge I mean the
annihilation wave captured Galactus and
used him as an energy source there were
a lot of things that went on so this is
not just like a small thing it's not
grabbing you know some some army from
some you know cast-off planet somewhere
or what's left of the denizens in the
universe and then making one last you
know game and trying to destroy Thanos
this is a massive army but they are
cannon fodder they're mindless soldiers
they're just there and they're easily
destroyed they're fish in a barrel is
really all they are and so the result is
a Thanos and Ghost Rider tear through
these guys and it's just a combination
of all the fan oohs all the power that
US possesses is a combination of all the
Power Ghost Rider possesses they just
start ripping through these guys with
virtually no effort whatsoever and so
the result is that what we end up having
here is that Thanos comes to the
realization that something's not right
and I want you to think about this for a
second in what we would call the modern
day right now in Marvel Comics you know
we're talking about a Stannis it's been
around for a long time been around for
what amounts to centuries and this guy
has learned all these different things
when it comes to the military strategy
he's learned the ins and outs of like
how characters are most likely going to
fight how they think it's just something
that he's attained over the years by
virtue of facing off against the same
heroes over in over and over again and
experiencing defeat after defeat after
defeat and so in his mind when he looks
at the Silver Surfer the Silver Surfer
doesn't usually jump into a conflict he
doesn't believe he can win but these are
desperate times and at the Silver Surfer
is willing to reach out to a force that
would have just as easily turned against
him as join him then the Silver Surfer
has to have something else up his sleeve
if the surfer knew if Aniston ghostrider
would easily destroy these guys then
there has to be something else going on
and so what is up happening is a vanos
asked this question what are you doing
like one why haven't we seen you for a
while to what have you been doing when
we haven't seen you in three what would
you show up here with what amounts to
cannon fodder that would get obliterated
in effectively minutes yeah and then in
turn just kind of stay and you know the
silver surfers response is well I've
been working
I've been waiting I haven't you know
I've been lying in wait and just kind of
resting on my laurels I've been working
and when the question is what have you
been working on this silver surfers
response is I've been working on
becoming worthy and that's when we end
up finding out somehow or another the
silver surfer has attained the hammer of
Thor without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained and make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the robb cork you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]